arranca el juicio contra alexey navalli
otro juicio más en este caso se le juzga
acusado de extremismo se le acusa de
haber creado una organización extremista
que financia el extremismo que se Sirve
también de menores y que incluso
rehabilita el nazismo recordemos que el
líder opositor ruso alexi lleva preso
desde el año 2021 un año Antes había
sido envenenado presuntamente por las
propias autoridades rusas desde que fue
apresado está cumpliendo pena de prisión
por delito de estafa hoy en esta nueva
vista de este nuevo juicio los abogados
no han podido acceder a la sala tampoco
su familia Aunque sí que han podido
seguir el proceso desde una instancia
desde una habitación cercana por vídeo
desde diversas organizaciones opositoras
y colectivos de Derechos Humanos se han
denunciado que se trata de otro juicio
político contra Alexa Y na